hi my name is chef not tocrawl I work
with the SR group and first of all I
would like to state that it's such a
fantastic feeling to see the World
Economic Forum get the India economic
summit to Mumbai I was a big supporter
of that cause and I'm happy that it's
happened so congratulations to so Shawn
and the entire team at the World
Economic Forum secondly it's always
great to come to the web because you get
to hear so many ideas you get to meet so
many interesting people and you kind of
get an update of what's happening in the
world so very very happy to be here and
again I wrote got roped in to moderate a
session on rural livelihoods and
economic prosperity and inclusive growth
I took him back to my previous days of
being a TV moderator but it was amazing
to see how through dialogue which is the
basis of the World Economic Forum
through dialogue so many issues can come
to the forefront and we can actually
talk of solutions so best of luck and I
hope this summit has achieved its
purpose of at least trying to show us
the path to higher growth so good luck
to web and I look forward to the Davos
summit from here on thank you